interstellar is directed by Christopher
Nolan and stars Matthew McConaughey Anne
Hathaway Michael Caine Jessica Chastain
Casey Affleck someone else I'm not gonna
say in case you don't know this movie
portrays our planet at some unspecified
time in the future in which we are
running out of food the dirt is just not
providing food anymore like it used to
and people are starving and when the
possibility of an interstellar voyage
utilizing a wormhole becomes an
opportunity for Matthew McConaughey he
leaves his family behind in search for a
possibly inhabitable world this movie
had one press screening in Cleveland and
that was on Monday I did not get into
this because I'm not cool enough to join
those people I guess that's fine I went
with a good buddy of mine to the closest
theater near me that was showing it
tonight and that was Pittsburgh 100
miles away in 35 millimeter film that my
friends is what I call dedication I was
also really excited to the movie I mean
Christopher Nolan in my opinion is one
of the best directors working today his
films are imaginative they're fun
they're exciting they're big and they're
all really good so I was like ok
interstellar this is gonna be my
favorite movie of the year
I can't wait to see this movie it's
gonna be flawless it's gonna be perfect
is it all those things No
interstellar is not a perfect movie
there are some flaws involved with it
the script has some issues there are
some narrative structure problems some
aspects of the way the film ended did
not have the emotional punch that I felt
was needed but I was riveted for almost
the entire runtime of this movie because
I genuinely did care about Matthew
McConaughey's character his family life
back home the entire setup of his family
was so well done and the launch into
space and that entire mission was so
incredible and the CGI was seamless I
barely even noticed any CGI I mean
honestly and what I don't even notice
CGI and it just becomes part of the
movie part of the environment that is
praise worthy I don't have to tell you
that Hans Zimmer's score is fantastic it
is I don't have to tell you the movies
directed very well it is I don't have to
tell you the CGI is good like I just did
you guys all knew those things were
going to be good how's the story very
interesting and without spoiling
anything I did
think a lot of the aspects of the way
the film concluded were great but the
last 10 minutes of the movie I felt were
completely unnecessary too convenient
and too much like a perfectly wrapped
gift it just all felt too perfect like
the way Inception concluded what they
were aiming for that catharsis and
Killian Murphy's character and they got
it and it just felt like oh yes this is
so emotionally powerful I didn't feel
that way in the end of interstellar they
wanted me to but I just felt like wow
this is really well directed and I wish
that I was feeling like I cared more in
this moment no I don't want to come off
like I didn't like this movie because
for goodness sakes I did this is gonna
be a day one blu-ray purchase for me I'm
gonna go to Walmart Monday at midnight
and have them dig it out of the box I
can't wait to see the film in digital
clarity because I just saw it in 35
millimeter film with not the greatest
sound but I really did enjoy this movie
I have to praise its ambitiousness
because it really has a lot of huge
ideas and it was kind of like Nolan just
threw himself at the mercy of everyone
just like look this is what I want to do
here's all of it just blending vomit of
ideas and he just put it all out there
some of it doesn't work and some of it
really does but the stuff that does
really does there are moments of
brilliance in this movie there are long
stretches where my eyes were glued there
were moments where my mouth dropped I
got goosebumps at a couple parts I had
to pee like the last 90 minutes of this
movie and I didn't get up I was so into
it that it kind of eclipses my qualms
with the way the film concluded even
though I wanted a little more ambiguity
from the way the film ended and more of
an emotional punch to the film I still
was so entertained by everything that
came before that the movies themes of
what our place in life is what our
existence is what our purposes are all
really well realized Anne Hathaway is
very good in the film despite not really
caring all that much about her character
around all these amazing visual treats
that your eyes are getting McConaughey
is the anchor that brings this movie
back down to earth he's terrific in the
movie is he as good of a character as in
true detective no but true detective had
8 hours to build a character you know
what I mean he was just perfect in this
movie he really was the space sequences
were just mind-blowing some truly epic
stuff going on definitely a lot of
inspir
from 2001 a Space Odyssey in there and a
really funny robot character that I
truly did not expect to be as awesome as
he was I felt attached to his daughter
when he was still on earth the emotional
connection between them was so real and
raw and powerful and I really felt that
it didn't seem faked it felt totally
real like all of the space mission stuff
was great it's just that the way the
film wrapped up and like I said no
spoilers there's a moment when you think
the film might be ending at that point I
feel if it had ended it would have been
a lot better than it was but it goes on
for about another 10 minutes and I was
like hmm I don't know about this but
like I said guys I honestly really
enjoyed watching this movie and I can't
wait to see it again
I am gonna give interstellar a b-plus I
think it's a very good movie I think it
has a lot of great ambition great
performances directed pristinely it was
cool to see it in a nostalgic way in the
35 millimeter film despite being in a
really crappy theater but the story does
have some issues some of the narrative
structure feels a little broken and
there isn't that emotional punch I was
looking for in the way the film
concluded guys if you have seen
interstellar what are your thoughts on
it and stay tuned this weekend probably
on Sunday
I will release a spoiler filled
discussion of interstellar with my good
buddy who I saw the movie with Craig
candy co-founder of phat movie guide.com
to look forward to that guys so I'm
gonna go in-depth about everything in
that video guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you did like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes